The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot
com. Remember to grab a membership at join
Pacman dot com and support The David Pakman Show.
We have a great place on the Internet for you to
engage with our other viewers and listeners.
It's the David Pakman show subbrand it which
you can find at David Pakman dot com slash. Read
it. A few interesting posts from this morning.
If Trump loses the election fair and square, what
do you think he'll do as president during during
the interregnum period, also known as lame duck? I
think this is a user on our subject. I think he'll
probably pull a Matt Bevin and pardon a bunch
of heinous criminals, murderers, rapists, etc.
That's his way of lashing out against the
public who he will feel betrayed him. I
also think he'll probably try to start a war or
something before he leaves office so he can hand
the conflict over to Biden. I don't know about
starting a war. I do think that if Trump loses
and it is clear that he lost and Trump has no way
to argue he didn't lose. I do think that there
is a real risk of complete and total insanity
during that lame duck period now. Hopefully by
that point, the world will be so desperate for
normal people in the White House that Joe Biden
will essentially become the president in waiting.
He will be running a parallel presidency, directly
interacting with world leaders. And Donald Trump
will immediately be pushed to the margins. But
let's not put the cart before the horse.
And remember, my other concern is physical
violence, physical violence from Trump supporters
during that lame duck period. If they believe
Donald Trump had it stolen from him. So let's
take it a day at a time. Let's first remove Trump,
then we'll figure out how to handle the lame
duck period. Another post from the sub read it
says, Joe Biden should not attend the debate
next week. I knew someone who experienced
Cauvin symptoms for five weeks and was probably
still infectious during that time. We have no
idea what Trump is truly experiencing right now.
He'll still likely be contagious next Thursday.
Biden should not participate. Well, Joe Biden may
have been bailed out because Donald Trump now says
he will not participate because the Commission
on Presidential Debates has decided as of this
second, it already may have changed by the time
we get today's show out. As of this second,
the CPD says next week's debate will be
remote because of the situation as we know it.
And Donald Trump has said he won't participate.
So we will see. But I understand your concern.
The last thing we need is Joe Biden getting
the virus from Donald Trump. And then lastly,
from the sub Reddit user Flame Boy
says, unless I've missed something.
Did anyone else notice there's been no videos
released of bunker babies since he got back
to the White House? It'll be interesting to
see how long it is until we see another one
with all of his cronies repeatedly saying that
everything is fine. Well, we finally got a
video from Trump from from the White House. And
that's what I will talk about next. But you can
join the discussion on The David Pakman Show sub
Reddit at David Pakman dot com slash r e d DHT.